this is after months of delay the Senate
Intelligence Committee released its
Declassified summary containing details
of mistreatment it says the CIA misled
the White House and public over
techniques described as brutal and
ineffective there may never be the right
time to release this report the
instability we see today will not be
resolved in months or years but this
report is too important to shelve
indefinitely it documents the CIA's
harsh interrogation methods including
simulated drowning or waterboarding seen
here reenacted by human rights activists
in Washington in us run prisons like
Guantanamo captives were deprived of
sleep for up to 180 hours other abuses
included beatings chuckling even threats
to harm their families I can
categorically say that anybody who
engaged in any behavior like this would
be directly violating my executive
orders and my policies as president
United States and would be held into
account and would be breaking the law
many Republicans condemned the report
and it's litany of abuses committed
during the Bush era one of its few
supporters was John McCain himself a
former prisoner in Vietnam and torture
victim I know from personal experience
that the abuse of prisoners will produce
more bad than good intelligence
Washington is now concerned that the
report could enflame anti-american
sentiment and lead to new terrorist
attacks meanwhile critics are calling
for a sweeping security overhaul